عمل وجوه
ما ادري شنو
عمل وجوه هو القدره او عدم القدره عفوا
على التعرف على الوجوه وهي مشكله صحيه
حقيقيه ربما تكون مرتبطه تخيلوا بكورونا
هذا كله بحسب دراسه علميه حديثه توصلت الى
رابط محتمل اعاده ما بين كوفي 19 طويل
المدى ومشاكل التعرف ايضا على الوجوه
الانتقائيه يمكن ان تكون من الاعراض
النادره لفيروس كوفيد طويل المدى وفق
تقرير جديد نشره موقع
وعمل وجوه هو حاله يولد بها ما يقدر بنحو
ثلاثه بالمئه من سكان الارض يصاب به حوالي
واحد من كل
ثلاثين الف نتيجه لثلاث مناطق في الدماغ
مخصصه
لمعالجه الوجوه او التعرف عليها طبعا
بعتقد الاشخاص اللي بيعانوا من هذه
المشكله راح يستفيدوا من شريحه ايلون ماسك
الدماغيه بحيث بصير فيه كمبيوتر
مش قادر يتعرف على الوجه بينزل الوجه مع
اسمه وكل التفاصيل عنه زي ما بنشوف
الافلام
نسائي وانت الهوى بالنسبه لي والمايك كمان
لا الوجوه اتذكرها بس انسى يعني اربط هذا
بالضبط
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات